so meine Damen und Herren die
innenausschusssitzung ist gerade nach
drei Runden der Befragung von
Innenministerin Feser vornehmlich zur
Affäre Schönbohm unterbrochen worden zur
Fortsetzung im eingestuften Modus wurde
uns mitgeteilt dass Frau Feser noch
weshalb eins Zeit hat wegen der dann
erfolgenden Befragung im Plenum da die
Zeit jetzt sehr eng wird gebe ich Ihnen
mal den Zwischenbericht was in drei
Runden der Befragung herausgekommen ist
und was nicht eine große Rolle spielt
das Schreiben des Anwalts von Herrn
schönbom in dem Herr schönbum zum Zwecke
der Aufklärung im Ausschuss
ausdrücklich darauf verzichtet dass aus
Datenschutzrechtlichen oder
fürsorgepflichtsrechtlichen Erwägungen
heraus dass Ministerium sich über
irgendwelche Dinge in Schweigen will sie
kennen diese wording ja wir können
darüber wir würden ja gerne aufklären
aber aus Datenschutzrechtlichen können
wir nicht sagen Herr hat ausdrücklich
die Ermächtigung über seinen Anwalt dazu
erteilen lassen die Ministerin der das
vorlag hingegen hat wiederum diese
Einschränkung sich dienstbar gemacht
dass sie also da einiges nicht genaueres
sagen könnte aus diesem Grund sie ist
dann ausdrücklich befragt worden und es
gab
erhellenderweise vielleicht keine
Antworten auf folgende Fragen wieso hat
Herr König aus dem BMI im Ende Mai
letzten Jahres ein Dossier über Herrn
schönbum überhaupt erstellt das ist ja
ist ja ein Vorgang der erstmal zu
hinterfragen ist diese Frage wurde im
fragedurchlauf dem ein
beantwortungsdurchlauf folgt nicht
aufgegriffen obwohl die mehrfach
aufpoppte wie so gerade Ende Mai Anfang
Juni sie wissen das ist in zeitlicher
Nähe zur Kontaktnahme des BMI mit einem
fernsehsatiriker
wieso der überhaupt in dem Zusammenhang
kontaktiert wird ist eine andere Frage
dann der Anruf von Staatssekretär
Richter in dem er Herrn schönbom 2
Optionen nach Ausstattung der Sendung
unterbreitet hat freiwill rückt wird
oder
Disziplinarverfahren über ein Jahr
Ausgang offen obwohl das
Bundesverwaltungsgericht sagt maximal
drei Monate das wurde hinterfragt wieso
Herr Richter zu einer derartigen
einschüchterungsanruf darf man das
nennen ermächtigt wurde darauf wurde
nicht geantwortet wieso sind eine Satire
Sendung ein hinreichende Anlass für ein
Verbot der Dienstgeschäfte immerhin
vorher fand das nicht statt wenn jetzt
gesagt wird nein nein das alleine reicht
natürlich nicht vor der Sendung fand es
nicht statt danach fand es statt also
scheint das ein hinreichender Anlass zu
sein das wurde nicht beantwortet sie
haben die Meldung gesehen dass eine
hochrangiger vs Verfassungsschutz
Mitarbeiter sagt es hätte permanente
Anfrage gegeben
was seltsam ist weil wegen der höchsten
Sicherheitsfreigabe schön morgens man
ohnehin proaktiv formuliert hätte das
wurde ebenfalls hinterfragt darauf gab
es keine
Antworten das ist deshalb seltsam sie
alle kennen den vermerkt wir sollen noch
mal BFV Abfragen weil das würde ja
bedeuten dass die Ministerin Herrn
Böhmermann mehr aufklärungskompetenz
zutraut als Herrn Haldenwang eine
bizarre Vorstellung nach meinem
Dafürhalten da gab es leider keine
Aufklärung am 23 November letzten Jahres
hat eine BMI ihren Welten gesagt es gebe
nur schwache fachliche Vorwürfe dennoch
wurde mit der endgültigen Abberufung zum
ersten ersten nicht gewartet obwohl
wenige Tage später im Januar eine
Referentin empfohlen hat die
Voruntersuchung mit negativen Ergebnis
einzustellen danach haben wir gefragt
warum man in diesem Zusammenhang dass
ich nichts ergab dann das nicht
abgewartet hat keine Antwort darauf dann
ein ganz wichtiger Punkt um den es jetzt
in der dritten Runde sehr lange ging sie
kennen den Vermerk wo es heißt sie hat
uns gesagt sie fand die Dinge zu dünn
wir sollten nochmals bfv-abfragen und
alle Geheimunterlagen zusammentragen
danach wurde wie sie verstehen können
häufiger gefragt die Antwort ist immer
es fand keine
mehrmalige nochmalige Anfrage beim BFV
statt wenn sie mal ganz genau hinhören
merken sie dass die Antwort gar nicht
die Antwort auf die Frage ist denn
Vermerk heißt es weiter ich habe ihr
gesagt dass wir alle relevanten Behörden
und Abteilungen bereits beteiligt hätten
und es schlicht nicht mehr gäbe mit
anderen Worten es wird nur zugegeben
dass eine tatsächliche
Abfrage beim BFV dann nicht mehr
getätigt wurde parlamentarisch
interessant ist aber die Intention der
Ministerin dass sie etwas zu dünn findet
und noch mal
nachgehakt sehen will dass sie sich also
nicht objektiv informieren lässt und den
Sachstand akzeptiert dass es nichts gibt
sondern eine weitergehende persönliche
Intention hat die wurde dann zwar
korrigiert durch jemanden der ihr sagt
es gibt nicht mehr aber es bleibt was
nicht bestritten wurde ist die primäre
Intention ein wichtiger Unterschied
zum Schluss wurde auch gefragt nach dem
Simson langvermerk wir haben nichts
gefunden aber das Ziel ist ja erreicht
so fasse ich das mal zusammen sie kennen
diese Zitate wir haben auch danach
gefragt was denn dieses Ziel gewesen sei
auch darauf gab es keine Antwort die
der Verdacht dass hier aus sachfremden
Gründen einem
konzertierter Feldzug einer Ministerin
stattgefunden hat die einen aus welchen
Gründen auch immer unliebsame
Behördenleiter
abberufen wollte und dann im Nachhinein
alle Hebel die möglich und unmöglich
sind versucht in Bewegung zu setzen um
nachzuweisen dass sie dazu berechtigt
sei dieser Verdacht wurde auch heute
nicht ausgeräumt und das bedeutet ja
nichts anderes als dass sie die Macht
ihrer Funktion eingesetzt hat um eine
persönlich getroffene sachfremde
Entscheidung zu rechtfertigen dass es
kein mögliches Verhalten eines deutschen
Ministers das ist der Stand zur Stunde
vielen Dank
nach unserer Meinung der afd-fraktion
ist wenn das die Antworten oder nicht
antworten sind auf diese doch
gravierenden Fragen damit die
Voraussetzung für die Amtsführung um mal
den fäsischen Terminus gegenüber
schönbum aufzunehmen nicht länger
gegeben es kann nicht sein dass jemand
so sehr eine intens ein Unwillen den
zugeleiteten nichts ergebenden Sachstand
zu akzeptieren an den Tag legt und das
dann auch noch durch immer weitere
Rotationen versucht zu objektivieren das
ist quasi eine Art Amtsmissbrauch um
sich selber in seinen
vorauseilenden überschießenden Maßnahmen
reinzuwaschen das geht nicht
nach der Art und Weise wie heute nicht
geantwortet wurde
bin ich mir ziemlich also man kann ja
immer eine Antwort versuchen die die
Opposition dann vielleicht nicht
zufrieden stellt aber wenn man nicht
antwortet ist das was anderes als wenn
man regierungsseitig eine Antwort
versucht auf diese genannten Fragen nach
der Art und Weise wie heute nicht
geantwortet wurde sind wir uns
ausreichend sicher gleichwohl kann ein
Untersuchungsausschuss der in dieser auf
diese Dinge noch weiteres Licht wirft
nicht schaden sie kennen die dafür
nötigen Quoren
es gibt einen Weg den Unterschied fand
eine Instrumentalisierung im Sinne einer
letztabfrage tatsächlich statt oder lag
eine Intention dies zu tun vor ich habe
vorhin versucht klar zu machen dass
diese uns dieser feiner Unterschied
wichtig ist wir sollten heißt es im lang
Vermerk noch mals bfv-abfragen ich habe
ihr gesagt dass wir alle relevanten
bereits beteiligt hätten das Licht nicht
mehr gäbe daraus stellte sich mir so da
dass das dann was auch heute häufig
bekundet wurde nicht faktisch stattfand
aber die Intention bestand das tun zu
wollen und warum man das tun will wenn
vorher nichts zugetragen wird aus
eigener Intention wenn Herr schönbum
eine Sicherheitsfreigabe hat die sowieso
proaktive Belieferung durchs BV
erfordert hätte
dafür gibt es keine sehr gute
Rechtfertigung
also ich habe mich bemüht eine Reihe von
Punkten zu nennen die nicht beantwortet
wurden warum gab es das können Dossier
warum gab es das Telefonat in dem ein
non-standard Disziplinarverfahren
angedroht wurde als Druckmittel für den
Rücktritt
warum gab es überhaupt eine endgültige
Abberufung im Januar nachdem schon im
November eine bmi-anwältin sagt da ist
fachlich eigentlich wie heißt es nur
schwache fachliche Vorwürfe und dann der
letzte Punkt über den wir gerade
gesprochen haben Unterschied Intention
dienstbarmachung BFV oder tatsächlicher
Umsetzung all diese Punkte das mögen
feine Punkte sein aber zur Ausleuchtung
einer Intention sind es wichtige Punkte
und in denen ist nicht Aufschluss
gegeben worden bzw auf einer Art und
Weise nichts gesagt worden dass es schon
widersprechend ist